10 years 10 years 10 years here we go as
Marvel Studios celebrates our first 10
years we want to thank you the fans
who've made it all possible by giving 10
Marvel super fans the chance to win the
ultimate Marvel Studios experience and
proud our 10 year anniversary
celebration we'll be diving deep into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe like never
before with exclusive content and untold
stories we've been capturing since the
first Iron Man film ten years ago your
passion is the reason for our success
so from everyone at Marvel Studios thank
you thank you thank you thank you
sweepstakes prizes include a Captain
Marvel set visit a Marvel Studios tour
and the tickets of the world premiere of
Avengers infinity
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey pancit food looks really good too
oh good good just trying to focus all
right look don't my dad said to me just
before I died Oh me there because I
wasn't there
I was too busy obsessing on my gamma-ray
experiments I missed my father's death
because I was focusing on my destiny but
I didn't miss my father's death because
he was murdered right in front of me by
my sister whom I didn't even know
existed because she was kept a secret
from me my whole life like terrible
comparisons had nothing to do with what
you're going through and my family it's
like would cost to fight amongst
ourselves while everyone else suffers
for it no I was gods and runes and well
this is sister hello I don't even know
if I have veto your for you could kill
your sister thought without his humma
you're not the god hammers here Dumbo
doesn't sound like a compliment it's
totally a compliment Dumbo Dumbo this
sounds like you're calling me Dumbo over
and over again Dumbo
say once more not a herd of elephants
who think she can fly because it was a
magical feather and then he loses his
feather one day and he realizes didn't
have anything to do with him flying at
all it was inside of him freaking
feather man would I come from
was that me the whole time you think out
his tail didn't even say anything we're
here
yeah yeah get rid of it hey everybody a
whole bunch of footage just dropped for
infinity war if you didn't see it they
dropped another promo with a bunch of
behind-the-scenes footage we got a look
at the Infinity Gauntlet with four of
the six gems and it giving us an idea of
which order or Thanos collects them and
and then obviously there's that funny
thor ragnarok scene that's from the
deleted scenes the Blu ray / that's
coming out in the next couple of weeks
but I think it's out on digital right
now so if you haven't seen it we do need
to talk about Thor Ragnarok stuff during
infinity war is very important for some
of the changes to the characters so if
for some reason you haven't seen it yet
make sure you check it out before you
see infinity war but let's start with
the big stuff first the Infinity
Gauntlet there are four gems this is
verified as the gauntlet or reference
for the gauntlet that Thanos actually
wears during infinity war
he's like a 10 foot tall character so
it's not like Josh Brolin walks around
with this version of it on his hand but
they use this as a reference for the CG
that they add later
so they scan this in and this is what it
winds up looking like on screen although
I'm sure that they're gonna polish this
CG a little bit more like this is
probably a primitive version of what
this scene will look like when they're
done with it obviously this is flipped
around but left to right starting with
the thumb so the green time gem goes in
the thumb you can't see any lights
bumping up against there so I'm assuming
it's not on the gauntlet here but then
you have the purple power gem the blue
space gem which is in the tesseract at
the beginning of the movie the red
reality gem the last time we saw that
was at Thor the dark world given to the
collector there's actually a scene that
I just posted from infinity war where
Thanos is beating the crap out of the
collector trying to find it almost a
link to that at the end of this then the
orange soul gem and then in the middle
like the really big one is the yellow
mind gem I've already gotten a couple
questions about why the one in the
middle is so much bigger than the others
the gems themselves will change size
depending on the slot that Thanos puts
them in so like look how big the
gauntlet is compared to Josh Brolin in
real life so like all the other Marvel
heroes are normal sized human beings or
androids like vision who's the same size
as a normal person the reason why some
of them could wear the gauntlet if they
tried is because the gauntlet itself
will also
change sizes depending on the size of
the person that's wearing it so when
Thanos is wearing it the gauntlet is
really big but when spider-man or Iron
Man or Captain America tried to wear it
it would just shrink down to the size of
their hand but this is actually a pretty
big deal because it sort of backdoor
confirms that the last two gems that
Thanos is going to get are the Green
Time gem from Doctor Strange and visions
yellow mind gem so that completely blows
away my idea for what the timeline of
the gems was originally because we keep
asking about the soul gem that's the
last one that we have never seen before
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so we all assumed that that was gonna be
the final gem that he would put in the
gauntlet but this sort of implies when
we see that Captain America seen with
vision in them walking into the Avengers
facility it looks like he's just gotten
his ass handed to him after this big
scene with the Black Order that he still
has the mind gem they are not successful
in taking it from him that seems also
important for another reason because
people saw it and they're like wait a
minute is Captain Marvel standing behind
Captain America so I was gonna do a
separate video about this but just
cliffnotes know that is scarlet which
you can actually see her red hair behind
him the reason why people think that
this might be Captain Marvel is is
because of jenkees screen caps so like
when things get pixelated the colors mix
a little bit in this red of her hair
starts to look like yellow so people
think that it's from Captain Marvel's
yellow stripes on her costume so no
hopefully that clears that up
that Scarlet Witch it's right after this
scene here where Captain America Black
Widow in Falcon come to help them fight
off Corvus glaive in Proxima midnight so
it's attached to this scene here they're
like okay we finally beat them off now
let's limp back home to the Avengers
facility but also on the Doctor Strange
side of things because they come for the
sanctum you see all this destruction
here it looks like ebony maw is also
unsuccessful and taking the time gem
from Doctor Strange in this scene here
now we have a better idea of why
Thanos's out riders are invading Wakanda
it's probably to come get the mind gem
from vision vision is probably being
helped out by Sheree in there wakandan
technology to figure out how to separate
him from the mind job so that he won't
die so now you're like wait a minute
what about that scene where Thanos has
the Infinity Gauntlet two gems in it
punching Iron Man
on what looks like the wreckage of x'
and are like what's what's going on here
why doesn't he have more of the gems if
he has the red reality gem and the
orange soul gem in the gauntlet here
like where does this scene happen during
the movie because it sounds like a whole
bunch of stuff happens before Iron Man
goes into outer space like we just saw
this scene with them and spider-man on
Thanos his ship in the sky here there's
still a lot of questions about what's
going on to the timeline but what this
picture seems to imply is is that by
this big final battle scene I'm guessing
this is happening towards the end of the
film is as the Thanos has all four of
these gems so unless this CG picture is
thor ragnarok style purposefully
misleading then this scene is happening
much earlier in the film and at some
point between this scene in this final
big outriders invasion of Wakanda he
gets those other two gems but if you
were actually in the audience at Comic
Con he was actually fighting The
Avengers on this place here and there
were some asteroids floating around them
he used the Infinity Gauntlet to hook
one of them atom it'll probably show up
in the next trailer that they drop which
should be in the next month or so
moving into the thor ragnarok scene so
obviously this is just a funny moment
with them just trying to cram as many
jokes as possible into this final scene
it probably got cut because it wasn't
essential for the story but they make a
joke about Dumbo but remember they had
that Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory joke where he's going to meet
the Grand Master and goes on the Willy
Wonka ride that just looks like a crazy
LSD nightmare trip make all the tentacle
jokes that you can think of remember
they said that the Grand Master used
this ship for orgies don't touch
anything
there's a Jack Kirby illustration on the
doors behind them of the Grand Master
but that's about it it's just supposed
to be a really funny clip in related
news there is a new Jessica Jones season
2 trailer I'll do a breakdown of that
next but there is a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
share the video using those tools in the
watch page because the Olympics is
started now be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss any
of the videos because new stuff will be
dropping but congratulations to the
winner from my last video James Warren
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
winner when I post new Marvel but click
here to watch that daños infinity war
scene where he comes for the reality gem
and click here to watch that last big
promo they released thank you so much
for watching everybody
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]